the epic battle on EAD Island just keeps
heating up because the One Piece manga
has just revealed that another insanely
powerful force is about to join the
fight because right at the end of the
chapter we do see some mysterious Force
destroying a marine Battleship that was
actually sent itself to destroy the
civilians who tried to escape from eekat
and so to really make sense of what
we're seeing here and who is coming
let's first go back to chapter
1089 because here it's where we first
learned that the ship with all of the
EAD citizens has evacuated the day
before this event which at first glance
might not seem like a big deal but is
actually a super important detail that
we'll discuss in a lot more depth in
just a moment but also in that chapter
we see that once the Marines had located
that ship St Saturn just like he did on
AAR ordered the immediate execution of
all of them because he didn't want any
of EAD secrets to escape the islands and
now if we jump back to the Cur current
chapter here we do know that someone has
destroyed that marine Vessel that was
sent to wipe out the evacuated citizens
and the reason why this is so exciting
here is that if someone is here taking
out Marine ships well then that means
that an entirely new group of characters
could soon be joining the massive chaos
going on at ekit and honestly no matter
who you have in mind who it might be
it's probably not going to be who you
expect because for one the most
straightforward assumption here that I
do think that Oda himself wants all of
us to believe is that this is actually
the work of the Blackbeard pirat since
we have been waiting for them to do
something around egad ever since we saw
one of their ships arriving at egad Way
Way Back In chapter
179 however this absolutely cannot be
those Blackbeard Pirates since we do
know that the civilian ship left the day
before the current events in other words
they should be pretty far away at this
point while the Blackbeard pirates that
we saw arriving on the island well they
were right there even before the battle
started and so while Blackbeard or some
of his crew might still be around well
if it's not them who else could this
possibly be and of course the first
option that I'm just going to throw out
here even though I personally don't
really believe in it would of course be
the straw hat Grand Fleet and I mean the
main reason is that we've all been
waiting for these guys to do something
in the story for ages now but we've seen
Luffy in way worse situations before
than this right now and they have never
shown up at that point so I'm not really
counting on any of the grand Fleet to
show up at this time around and so the
next option here is that this could be a
completely different group still of the
Blackbeard Pirates because you have to
remember that we do know that Blackbeard
was somewhat near ekad Island since he
did clash with law very soon after the
surgeon of of death left wano together
with Luffy and kits and so it would be
entirely possible that even if
Blackbeard isn't already at EAD on that
one ship we saw well he could still be
close by on a second ship and if that
were to be true then of course we just
have to ask why he would take out the
Marines here and the best answer here is
honestly not so that he can save the
poor citizens but so that he could take
them hostage and use them later to get
something that he really wants from Dr
Vega Punk or the government now whether
this would be some sort of weapon or
maybe some cloned devil fruit or
something or again joining the celestial
dragons we can't really know or if he's
making his way to ekad Island right now
that would obviously add a ton to the
already ongoing battle but still even
though I do think that this is a real
legit option and might happen it is far
from the most exciting and likely option
that we do have here because in fact I
personally would be a lot more excited
if a completely different Blackbeard
Pirate was on their way here because it
is entirely possible that instead of his
captain the former Marine Admiral Kon
could be the one traveling to egad and I
mean think about it wow if the ice fruit
user was truly the one coming to egad
then there are just so many connections
that we have to make here because in
case you forgot Kuan was also present
during the first Buster call on the
island of Alara and that specific event
has way too many connections already to
the events on egad Islands I mean just
started with that exact escaping
civilians ship for example because back
on aara the current Fleet Admiral Akainu
destroyed a similar civilian ship to at
that point prevent secrets from orara
escaping the island as well so wouldn't
it just be so fitting here that Kuan who
was also present back on ohhara would do
the exact opposite of his Marine
counterpart by saving the ship of
civilians because do remember even at
the Ohara incident Kuan let two other
people escape and that of of course was
Nico Robin and S because he was unclear
about what was actually the right thing
to do here and he really hoped that
Robin would prove to him that he was
right letting her live with her actions
in the future and so by destroying this
marine Vessel here Kuan could be showing
us that he now has a much clearer sense
of his own Justice and is determined not
to let the Marines kill any more
innocent civilians but of course that is
far from the only connection that Kuan
has on ekad island because if he were to
actually show up on ekit island here
that would also be the first time in
forever that he sees Robin in basically
over 2 years and I for one would be very
excited to see these two finally reunite
and interact again especially now that
the entire Straw Hat crew could actually
put up a real fight against the Chile
former Admiral and honestly we could
maybe even learn just how much loyalty
Kuan actually has to Blackbeard because
many people have speculated in the past
that Kuan has his own gos or or even
that the former Admiral could eventually
join the straw head crew instead still
hoping for that actually though
admittedly that would be a little bit of
a weird dynamic to have Robin and the
man who used to hunt her down on the
same crew so you know maybe uh it should
be kizaru after all besides that though
do sign me up for a Kuan versus kizaru
Clash because I would just love to see
what the current Admiral who's basically
a slave to the world government fighting
against his shackles right now while
battling against the man who actually
chose to leave the government himself
what that would look like I mean who
knows maybe kuan's arrival could
actually help knock some real sense into
kizaru finally tipping the balance here
and convince the flashy Admiral to
protect his friends and the people he
cares for instead of trying to kill them
and on top of that Kuan could of course
also inform the straw hats and Luffy
about garbs capture or death or whatever
really happened to him which could
actually pose a really interesting
dilemma for Luffy because if Garb is
captured does Luffy just abandoned his
grandfather and continu straight to elb
like we all basically have assumed and
which was basically confirmed by Vega
Punk or if he knows that GARP has been
captured by Blackbeard well would he
just go off and try to rescue his
grandpa back at pirate Islands either
way it's really hard to tell what would
happen here but it would be really
interesting to see Luffy have to choose
and Kuan could be the perfect person to
bring that information to ekad Islands
in other words if that wasn't super
obvious at this point clearly I am on
board the Kuan to egad Island train but
it doesn't really mean that there aren't
some other still mind-blowing
possibilities as well for one it could
be Viv and big news Morgans who were
supposed to be making their way over to
echad Island as well and obviously
saving a bunch of civilians is exactly
the kind of thing that Viv would want to
do herself however there is even one
other option that I actually think could
change the entire world and honestly I
just have to say the pace at which we're
going here 2024 is really really bound
to be an absolutely insane year for us
one piece fans and if you have someone
in your life that you can share your
love for one piece with that makes it
just the more exciting if you can just
sit down with them and watch it together
on the couch crunching down on some
truly delicious snacks though it's still
obviously awesome if you just do it by
yourself and if you don't know where to
get the perfect snack to watch and read
one piece 2 don't worry because I got
you this mysterious box is from today's
fantastic sponsor Sakura Co because it's
basically a monthly snackbook
subscription service that as you can see
is filled to the brim with just insanely
delicious authentic Japanese snacks from
local makers here in fact there is about
20 of these in each box and in fact even
though I have literally live in Japan
the snacks I buy here are Never As Good
As these and these boxes are actually
loved by my Japanese friends as well so
you kind of know it's legit like imagine
Sanji approving of any food that's kind
of what that that is now the theme of
this box in particular is Valentine's
Indulgence celebrating love and sharing
food with whoever you may watch One
Piece with or you know also great just
eating it by yourself with peach
dorayaki chocolate Danish mini heart
arade and much much more all explained
in this beautiful booklet right here
together with infos about Japanese
culture and I got to say I especially
love these Straw Hat chocolate crunches
which are just so good and not only will
you receive a delightful assortment of
Japanese snacks every month but you will
also get a curated selection of table
wear and tea for instance this month I
received this super cute Kiko plate and
this super calming cocoa CA that
perfectly paired with all of these
snacks and so if you also want the
perfect Japanese snack box from the
comfort of your own home to enjoy while
reading the perfect Japanese manga then
you can now use my exclusive code Ohara
for $5 off your very first sakuu order
which actually brings me back to this
chapter right here because do remember
that we still have this as well well
what if this Iron Giant wasn't the only
thing that woke up after hearing Luffy's
heartbeat in other words yeah I'm saying
there could be another ancient bit of
technology that also heard the drums of
Liberation from Luffy's heartbeat and is
heading back to EAD to find the source
of its calling so that's a wild one but
then there are also other possibilities
that we just have to throw out there as
well for one the Revolutionary Army
would certainly make a lot of sense for
why they would want to come I mean Kuma
came to echad Island and they were even
discussing where he could have gone so
they probably want to save him if they
can which as a coincidence would also be
the perfect opportunity for Dragon to
take down one of the goo which is after
all the main goal of the Revolutionary
Army in the first place but there is one
major obstacle for the revolutionaries
to show up here and that's basically
because they are literally on the other
side of the Grand line because as we
know the Revolutionary Army does now
have their new base at kabaka Kingdom
which is still in the previous part the
paradiz part of the grand line well akad
island is basically literally on the
other side of the world near the end of
the new world in fact the only reason
Kuma got here so fast from arija is
because he can teleport basically super
fast with his devil fruit but unless the
rest of the Revolutionary Army does have
some sort of flying or like super speed
Transportation power and really just
don't see how they could come here at
such a high speed however even if Dragon
doesn't make it in time to save luff and
Co an even strong of force it's much
much closer and that's of course that of
the red haad pirates because remember
that the last time that we saw them was
on albath which as far as we know at
least should be one of the next Islands
relatively close to egads and now you
might be asking well why would Shanks
want to come to ekad Island and that's
actually a great question because there
isn't really a great answer here I mean
yeah of course you could say ah you now
finally wants to come and see Luffy or
maybe he is after Luffy's copies of the
poneglyphs but why would he come at this
specific time right now yeah you got me
there however there is one person on
Alba with direct ties to many people on
egad island and that is of course the
giant Saul who we just recently Learned
was actually still alive and protecting
the knowledge that was saved from the
library of Hara and so in other words if
he learned that Vega Punk was in trouble
then I'm pretty sure that he would want
to help his former research buddy plus
there are Saul's ties to Robin as well
and their eventual reunion which just
has to happen but while we're throwing
out options then if Saul is coming to
egad it would make sense that he would
be bringing a whole crew of either
Shanks or the Giants with him which
should be more than enough to help the
straw heads win that battle here and
since we have been mentioning that a lot
now let's actually talk about that
battle because wow there was a ton to go
over from just this chapter one The
Marine battleships are finally going
crazy bombing the island Saturn has just
ordered all of the piif fistas to fire
their super lasers at Bonnie and Kuma
all while thinking how pathetic they are
which ouch CT and part of me wonders if
this is all going to backfire on Saturn
himself because I mean we've basically
spent the entire Arc going back and
forth with whose side the piif fista
actually are on and in the end it does
seem like no one can overrule Saturn but
now there might actually be one person
who can and that would of course be Kuma
who was the first original piif fista
that all the others are actually based
off in other words what if he somehow
actually managed to gain control of them
in the last moment maybe because of
something Vega Punk installed or through
Kuma's sheer willpower and he basically
orders them all to fire on Saturn
instead because that my friends would be
insane and deserved and I am 100% here
for it besides that though we basically
got an overview of what all of the other
straws are currently up to which
honestly is very helpful because there's
been a little bit too much to keep track
of hero neads which firstly and probably
most importantly we finally got an
answer to the many mysteries from the
last few chapters involving Luffy one we
wanted to know where he actually got the
food from and then where he disappeared
to last chapter and in a mindblowing
twist it was actually revealed that the
world government finally found a way to
keep Luffy from fighting them they
couldn't capture him they couldn't
defeat him with an admiral but in this
chapter when Luffy was confronted by the
Unstoppable temptation of a super
high-tech food vending machine Luffy Was
Defeated and helpless all jokes aside
here though what is Luffy doing right
now I mean I do know he is a hungry guy
and food is basically healing energy for
him but leaving a massive battle with
the goo while his friends lives are on
the line just so that he can have
another round of fast food just seems
like a little bit too much even for
Luffy like seriously kizaru nearly took
out Bonnie and Kuma again in this
chapter sanji's running back and forth
like a madman trying to save these two
and Vega Punk but Luffy is just you know
munching down on some food here which
again really really weird anyways
seriously though I'm I'm trying not to
be too disappointed with this and
instead focus on why Oda would want
Luffy to be separated at the moment
anyways and if you really think about it
he does this quite often during any
major battle because we've often seen
where Luffy is just going to be missing
or trapped somewhere or unable to help
the rest of the crew for a moment that
happened during thr La bark when he was
getting his nightmare power up and the
rest of the crew had to basically hold
off Moria by themselves it happened onr
Rosa when Luffy ran out of hockey for 10
minutes and even in wano after being
smacked off the Rooftop by kaido so it's
really not that this has never happened
before but usually Luffy isn't choosing
to be separated like he is this time but
then again maybe I'm just overthinking
this and Oda is just doing it to let
some of the other straws have some time
to shine as well a bit for example like
Sanji who is putting in work this
chapter or Frankie blasting St Saturn in
the previous one plus giving Luffy a
little bit of a timeout here does allow
us to rebuild some of our fear for the
main enemies because kizaru and Saturn
are truly threatening the rest of the
group for their lives while Luffy is
taking his Munch break and honestly I'm
sure that it will eventually pay off
when Luffy or someone else needs to step
up and protect the crew once again
however Sanji is not the only one
putting in some real work this chapter
and after nearly 20 chapters or so of
not seeing half of the crew we finally
got a recap of what's going on for most
of them for example Nami Chopper and
Robin are still back in the lap Robin
asleep for some reason then Brooke is
helping the Lilith Vega Punk to to get
the sunny in position to finally escape
from the island Zoro is still supposedly
off fighting Luchi I've completely
forgotten about that just honestly a
kind of something I'm hoping that we get
to see more of at some point I mean if
not then Zoro literally just had a major
fight for himself offc screen for 20
chapters or so but I do assume that
we'll get to see our greenhair swordsman
sooner than later because jimbe is now
heading off to either stop his fight or
to find him in case that he's just
straight up lost somewhere on the island
which let's be real might be the more
likely case here and so it does look
like we're finally heading for an escape
rather than a full out fight against the
government like we initially hoped for
one St Saturn actually arrived on the
island and truthfully I do think an
escape was always the most likely
scenario here I mean no one really
expected us to be at EAD once we left
wano in the first place so it does make
sense that we wouldn't truly have a
giant allout War here but then again if
the crew just does end up as escaping
successfully here I'll just have to
admit I would be a little bit
disappointed because basically the
entire Arc they've been building up this
hype and promise about a world shaking
event taking place here and feel like
we've kind of gotten it but not really
World shattering at this point and so
I'm very much hopeful for the end of
this Arc and more than excited for
whatever is coming next and to bring
this all the way back to the end of this
chapter if this mysterious savior is in
fact a group of giants coming from elff
to save the day then there would be no
better way than that to kick off that
Insanity that is bound to be the ALB Arc
with then an entire escort of giant
Vikings escorting the straw hats to the
islands and if all this chaos on ehad
plus the roller coaster of emotions that
was Kuma's backstory has gotten you all
mixed up about what we can actually
expect to happen next in the story then
this video right here is the absolute
perfect one for you to get all caught up
on what to expect from the legendary elb
Arc and everything that needs happen
there shks so much for watching please
like share subscribe I know it's
annoying but it does really help the
channel uh and uh I hope to see you in
the next one